بعد اللحظات مشاهدينا الكرام فقط وجها
لوجهه نخسيسها لاتهام مجلس الدوله الليبيه
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبي
بابي منعه من عقد جلسته في طرابلس التصويت
على قاعده الدستوريه برمتها والنظر في
اليه توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين
من المجلس الاعلى الى الدوله في ليبيا
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
الدبيبه بعرقله عقد جلسه للمجلس كانت
تصوتوا على القاعده الدستوريه برمتها
وستبحث اليه توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه وذلك
عبر قيام مجموعه عسكريه بمحاصره بمقره وسط
العاصمه مع ضيفيه مشاهدينا الكرام عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس السيد شعبان ابو سته عوده المجلس
الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا سيد شعبان ابو سته
اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا على تربيه
دعواتنا
اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا وشكرا لكم شكرا
بالفعل كل الترحيب بضيفنا في جانب المقابل
دائما من طرابلس في ال ال من العاصمه
الليبيه سيد فرج الدردور الاكاديمي
والباحث السياسي اهلا بك ايضا وكل الشكر
جزيلا لك على تربيه هذه الدعوه سيد فرج
الدردور
مساء الخير لك استاذ شعبان
وللمشاهدين ايضا كل الشكر كل الشكر لكم
على تلبيه هذه الدعوه تبعنا عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هذه السور التي انتشرت
واظهرت انتشارا همم كثيفا لعربات واليات
مسلحه وحيد بفندق في العاصمه والمجموعه
التي انتشرت في محيط مقر مجلس الدوله يقول
مراقبون انها تابعه لقوه حمايه الدستور
والانتخابات التي شكل لها همم رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد الطيبه مؤخرا
والتي تتبع في وزاره الدفاع في حكومته
وسؤالي ما تعليقكما على ما حدث بالامس
خطورته راح عليك السؤال الاول عن سيد
شعبان ابو سته عضو المجلس الاعلى للدوله
في ليبيا مرحبا من جديد
شكرا طبعا في البدايه ما حدث امس يعني
يحققها شيء مشير جدا يعني
كنا توقعه من الحكومه خاصه لان طبعا
المساله امس لم يكن فيها يعني تصويت ممكن
يكون ضد الحكومه بالعكس يعني هناك يعني
ممكن كان سيحدث التصويت في صالح الحكومه
في المجمل يعني سنه سوت على القاعده
الدستوريه بصفه عامه من جانبنا لكن مجلس
اعلن الدوله وبعد ذلك عن همم يعني حوالي
51 عضو من مجلس الاعلى للدوله سواء يعني
وقعوا على همم
بيان او مذكره تطلب من رئاسه المجلس ان ان
تضع اولويات في المرحله القادمه ومن ضمن
يعني انجاز القاعده الدستوريه وحدات
القوانين الانتخابات وعدم التطرق
للمناصبريه او تغيير السلطه التنفيذيه الا
بعد انجاز تلك المهام فحقيقه استغربنا امس
يعني ما حدث يعني ولما كنا نتوقعه من همم
طبعا السيد وزير الدفاع حضرت مجموعه الى
القاعه التي كنا سنعقد فيها الجلسه طبعا
نحن مجموعه الاولى يعني دخلنا الى القاعه
وبعد ذلك فجيئنا بعد الزملاء دخلوا وقالوا
بان طبعا هناك عسكريين خارج وانهم طلبوا
منهم المغادره وقال احد الزملاء انه عندما
سال المسؤول عنهم همم لماذا قال له انا
طبعا عسكري ومكلف من وزير الدفاع بهذه همم
ولما نستكمل البرنامج
طبعا السيد وزير الدفاع هو طبعا الرئيس
الحكومه طبعا لا اعرف لماذا هذا ومن
استشاره لفعل هذا يعني طيب ااا سيد ااا
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشي
يتحدث عن سابقه من نوعها سيد فرج الدردور
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي سابقه من نوعها
همم منذ 2001 10 بقيام رئيس الحكومه بمنع
السلطه السياديه عليا من اداء مهامها بهذا
الشكل بالقوه يصف ايضا حتى حكومه دبي
بانها ميليشياويه تريد فرض سيطرتها بالقوه
ما تعليقك انت على ما حدث هل همم كان لابد
منه
ليه اول انا ليست سابقه من نوعها يكفي ان
السيد المشري هو في جسم موازي تشريعي وهذه
طبع الحقيقه لم يحصل في اي دوله في العالم
بانه هناك جسمين متناكفين تشريعين في دوله
واحده وبالتالي السيد المشري هو جزء من
المشكله بالنسبه للحادي طب طبعا اذا صحت
لان هناك قويل عليه والدليل ان الاستاذ
شعبان ابو سته تتحدث بينه ودخل قبل يعني
ما تحصل هذه الحادثه ولم يتعرض له احد
وبالتالي ان اعتقد اذا كانت العمليه مدبر
من الحكومه ولا منعت الجميع لكن يعني قد
يكون هذا موجود همم طبعا انا لا استطيع
الانفيه يؤكد ولكن همم لابد ان ناخذ
الموضوع من ابعاد اخرى يعني همم المساله
ليست بهذه البساطه همم هناك احتقان شك في
ذلك هناك تراجق بالكلام حتى عبر الصفحات
التويتر بين السيد المشري وبين السيد
السيد هذا موجود لكن ال- الاشكاليه ليست
حتى في البيت على فكره همم لابد ان تعلم
ان هناك قاعده كبيره تؤيد اليوم في دبيبه
ليس لانه همم رئيس حكومه مثلا يعني باهر
او شيء من هذا القبيل ولكن لانه يقوم بمثل
هذه الاجراءات لردع
مجموعه معينه في مجلس الدوله من القيام
ببعض الاجراءات العبثيه لابد النعيم جيدا
ان مجلس الدوله هو جزء جسم مناكف للمجلس
النواب الموجود في منطقه الشرقيه
ووجوده هو ل- همم
لاحتفاظ ببعض التوابط اللي مختلف عليها
وبدليل انهم ما زال منفصلين لان هذه
التوابط ما زال مختلفين عليها لكن عندما
يخطف السيد المشري عن طريق تياره المؤدلج
واحنا نعلم همم السيد البشري هو يتبع تيار
الاخوان المسلمين والشق من تيار الاخوان
المسلمين ومجموعه الاخرين لحزب الديمقراطي
ويستغلونه ويستعملون هذا الجسم
له قضاء مصر حوائجهم الخاصه
والمحاصه في المناصب السياديه والاستمرار
في الحكم وبالتاكيد يعني اعضاء مجلس
الدوله محترمين احنا لا نضعهم جميعهم في
سنه واحده ولكن بالتاكيد هناك من يجتمع
معهم في هذه المصلحه فنعتقد بهذه الحاله
فالصهر يعني هناك اختلاف كبير على وجود
هذا الجسم اللي وجود اصلا هو منافذ لمجلس
النواب والمهمه محدوده حتى يتم دمجه بشكل
همم اساسي في في في الجسم تشريعي واحد
يقوم بها المشبوها المؤدلجه همم
خالد المشهد المرفوضه طيب وسل ياتي على
ذلك همم ربما بتفاصيل اكثر خلال دقائق سيد
شعبان ابو سته همم عضو المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في ليبيا فما كان نقطه تتحدث عنها
ضيفي قبل ان نطرح عليك سؤال الموالي هي
الاجراءات لدعمه وصف على حد تعبير مسؤولين
في مجلس الدوله
ااا ومنعه من القيام باجراءات عباسيه
وتغريب المصالح الخاصه حتى نعود الى
الروايه دبيبه يقول ان المحتاجين امام
مجلس الدوله كان عددهم قليلا وان هو اعطى
تعليمات قوه الردع سيد بوسته التي بدورها
فرقتهم وامنتال المكان كاملا اظاف انه كلف
وزر وزير وزاره الداخليه عفوا بالتامين
الكامل غدا لمقر انعقاد مجلس الدوله ما
عدم المسح بحق المواطنين فتظاهر والاحتجاج
السلمي ربما هذه التصريحات يطمئنكم نوعا
ما ولكن اشار الى ان هناك ربما هذا همم
قاله ضيفي اشار الى ان هناك اطرافا او
طرفا عفوا لديه طموح في القفز بعد نحو احد
عشر عاما من السلطه التشريعيه الى السلطه
التنفيذيه عبر صفقه تقاسم سلطه تؤجل
الانتخابات هل تحاولون القفز
هلا في البدايه طبعا ااا يعني مقاله زميل
الدكتور بما ان مجلس الدوله يناكف مجلس
النواب حقيقه مجلس الدوله هو يمثل تيار
موجود في البلاد وهو تيار فبراير وهو تيار
سياسي عريض وقوي وموجود في التويدات في
المنطقه الغربيه وبالتالي هو يمثل هذا
التيار ويحاول ان يدافع على مبادئ ثوره
السابع عشر من فبراير همم
يعني نقول بان مجلس الدوله مختطف من السيد
خالد المشري هذا طبعا غير صحيح بدليل ان
اغلب الاعضاء او جل الاعضاء الذين وقعوا
على المذكره التي كانت ستعرض عليها سوفت
عليها مجلس الدوله يعني كانت يعني ضد رؤيه
رئيس مجلس الدوله يعني رئيس دوله ذهب الى
المغرب واتفقنا السيد عقيله في الذهاب في
المناصب السيديه وسلطه الفديه ولكن جل
اعضاء المجلس الذين وقعوا على المذكره
يرون بانه لا يجب التطرق الى المناصب
السياديه او تغيير الحكومه في الوقت
الراهن وانه يجب انجاز القاعده الدستوريه
واعداد قوانين الانتخابات وتحديد موعد
الانتخابات وبعد ذلك يمكن ان نفكر في
المناصب السيديه او او الحكومه وبالتالي
للقول بان المجلس مختلف هذا غير صحيح يعني
للاسف امس كان يعني منعنا من التصويت كان
سيكون وضع خارطه وهي يعني اقل شيء يعني
كانت في صالح عبد الحميده ماذا كان سي سوف
المجلس عليها امس وهو وضع خارطه
او تغيير السلطه التنفيذيه الا بعد
الا بعد انجاز القاعده الدستوريه ولكن
للاسف عبد الحميد بيبه امس يعني نقوله
بالليبي زي ماسك عصا وضربها امس كان سيكون
التصويت ربما في اتجاه الذي يراه هو انه
لا يتطرق لا يتترق السلطه التنفيذيه اول
مره السياديه ولكنه طبعا منع الجلسه ووضع
اعضاء مجلس الدوله الان في زاويه حقيقه لا
يحسدون عليها يعني الان لو نصوت على
الخارطه التي وضعناها قبل ان يتم محاصرتنا
ربما سيقول بان اعضاء مجلس الدوله بتخوفون
من حدث وانهم يعني او غير ذلك ولكن طبعا
لازلنا احنا اعضاء مجلس الدوله من مهام
الرئيسيه للمجلس هي همم اعداد القاعده ضد
السوريه ووضع قوانين الانتخابات تحديد
موعد الانتخابات وبعد ذلك يمكن ان نتطرق
خلال المناصب السي دي او نتطرق الى تغيير
السلطه التنفيذيه بعد ذلك وبالتالي نحن
نرى ان يجب ان نذهب في هذا الاتجاه ونتمنى
ان تعقد الجلسه في همم اللي هي من القادمه
ويتم التصويت على المذكره التي وقع عليها
الاعضاء طيب اشكرك سيد فرج الدردور
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي تحدثت عن الدعم
للسيد عبد الحميد البيبه في مواجهه المجلس
الاعلى من الدوله ولكن السيد خالد المشري
نفسه يقول ان المجلس الاعلى للدوله يتعرض
لحمله تشويه وشيطنا من قبل حكومه السيد
الدبيبه وهذا ما يقودني ما حدث بالامس
للسؤال هل نحن فعلا امام صراع من اجل
البقاء في السلطه في ليبيا السيد بيبي
يقول انه ليس متمسكا بالسلطه ولكن مؤشرات
كثيره يقول منتقدون تثبت عكس ذلك سيد
المشري تسال مخاطبانا بيبه لماذا تريد منع
عقد الجلسات هل لديك اعتراض على توحيد
السلطه التنفيذيه وتريد الاستفراد همم
بالسلطه في همم الغرب الليبي هل هذا هو
تحديدا هدف
الاستفراد بالسلطه في غرب ليبيا
هو في الحقيقه هو صراع الديوك لا شك في
ذلك لكن لابد ان نعلم ان مجلس الدوله ليست
تيار ليس التيار وانما هو يقاسم السلطه
التشريعيه مع مجلس النواب هذه سابقه حقيقه
يعني لا توجد في العالم وليس التيار يمثل
فبراير حسب السلطه
الاشكاليه الاشكاليه ان هذا الجسم تقريبا
في السلطه 10 سنوات
عديده همم بعد ان اعطاها بالفرصه الاولى
والفرصه الفرصه على اتفقوا على قاعده
دستوريه وانتخابات وضيع وجميع الفرس وما
يقومون به اليوم هو التكرار سواء كان قاعد
عند السوريه او تقاسم مناصب السياديه
الشعب قال كلمته وهي ان اخر فرصه او اخر
مرحله انتقاليه هي مرحله جنيف وذهب السيد
وخالد المشري وتنافسهم في في في في جنيف
ولكن فشل وخسر امام امامه وبالتالي عادي
مثلا مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله من جديد
وهذا طبعا المرفوض الان
كل الشعب تقريبا حتى في المنطقه الشرقيه
يعني على فكره يعني بالرغم الضغوطات
الامنيه خرجوا بجرافات وقاموا بهدم
البرلمان
وحرقه
لانهم يعني ساهمون لا بد يعني يريدون خروج
من هذه المرحله مجلس الدوله حقيقه يعني
قاسم
اعطيني
مصرف في ليبيا مركز يعطيني يعني الرقابه
الاداريه خذ انت كذا وانا كليب حقيقه ما
يهمنيش اشياء اخذ لها صالح هو شيخ اخذ همم
همم خالد المشري هذا لا يهم حقيقه ما
يهمني هو ان نذهب الى صندوق الاقتراع وبي-
ونمارس بكل حريه اختيار من يريد ان يحكمني
لكن حقيقه عشر سنوات ما زال مستمرين في
السلطه وما زال يعني يقابل فيك على اساس
انه عضو مجلس استشريعي فلا اعتقد يعني هذا
اليوم مثلا مقبول في فرنسا لا يخرج اليوم
على التلفاز واحد من البرلمان يقول انا
عشر سنين راني ما زلت همم في عضو مجلس
النواب في همم اعتقد ان يعني يقبل هذا
الامر همم بالتالي المساله احنا لسنا في
وضع مثال ايضا لابد حتى المجتمع الدولي
انت لاحد التامس اجتماع مجلس الاستلامن
همم كل تقريبا سواء كان الامريكان مندوب
امريكا مندوب فرنسا فرنسا همم مندوبين
الاخره جميعهم قالوا بان لا توجد يعني
بالتجربه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك حكومه او
تقاسم جديد للسلطه يجب الذهاب مباشره صحيح
للانتخابات
كان فعل نوايا انصافه والمجلس النواب
ويذهب للانتخابات
عن سؤال ربما اطرح سؤال بشكل اخر هل يخشى
السيد عبد الحميد دبيبه من توحيد السلطه
التنفيذيه هل يخشى من اختيار اعضاء جدد
للمناصب السياسيه باختصار حتى عود الى همم
ضيف السيد شعبان ابو سته ما يفسر ما حدث
بالامس
السيد دبي بكل صراحه قال اعطوني القاعده
الدستوريه وسوف نذهب انتخابات لكن انا
حقيقه ليس يعني لا افتش عن النوايا هذا ما
قاله لكن في جميع الاحوال لان اقول لك
المشهد في ليبي بشكل عام هو مشهد متمسك
بالكراسي هذا لا لا لا خلاف عليه ومن حيث
انتهيت قبل قليل سؤال ضيف السيد شعبان ابو
سته مبعوثه الامين العام للامم المتحده
الى ليبيا السيد عبد الله حذر من سبها
تحديدا من خطر التفكك الذي يواجه الدوله
اذا استمرت المراحل الانتقاليه لسنوات
المقبله التي كان يتحدث عنها الرئيس في
السيد فرج الدردور
لم يحن الوقت فعلا في ليبيا لوضع الخلافات
والمصالح الضيقه جانبا ووضع حد لهته
المؤسسات والحكومات المؤقته سيد شعبان ابو
سته عود المجلس الاعلى الدوله
نعم نعم انا الاوان تنتهي المراحل
الانتقاليه وان نذهب الى انتخابات هذا ما
طبعا جل اعضاء المجلس الاعلى للدوله هم
متمسكين بهذه الرؤيه يعني يجب انجاز
القاعده الدستوريه ووضع قوانين الانتخابات
وتحديد موعد الانتخابات هذا موقع عليه 51
عضو من اعضاء مجلس الاعلى للدوله يعني هذا
ما تمسكون نحن نرى ان ال ال او الهويه
الان هي توحيد السلطه
التشريعيه والذهاب الى الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وقبلنا حتى في الحوارات في
القاهره ان نذهب الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ولكن للاسف يعني توقفنا عند نقطه طبعا لم
يقبلها الطرف الاخر وهي متزوجين الجنسيه
وترشح العسكريين وبالتالي يعني همم هذه
النقطه يعني كل كل يعني طبعا هيرفضون يعني
يترشح المتزوجين الجنسيه والعسكريين يعني
لا ابدا ان تضع لها قواعد هذه المساله
وبالتالي نحن يعني متمسكون وهذا ما قدمناه
في مذكره يعني مذكره كانت ستعرض امس انه
هو الاولويه بالنسبه للمجلس للدوله الذهاب
الانتخابات انجاز قاعده دستوريه والذهب
للانتخابات هذه اولوياتنا يعني الخوض الان
في المناصب السياديه او تغيير الحكومه ليس
هو
الاساس والليس هو من الاولويات الاولويات
هي الذهاب الى الانتخابات نحن فعلا مع
الذهاب الى الانتخابات وهذا وهو ما تمسك
به جل اعضاء المجلس الاعلى للدوله وما
نرغب همم في الذهاب اليه كون هناك عقيل
الطرف الاخر طبعا
الموازنين طبعا يرفض همم
همم بعض النقاط وراء ان يجوز للمتزوجين
الجنسيه ان يترشحوا او العسكريين يترشحوا
طبعا هذه المساله لقاءات ولا نستطيع ان
نحن نقول بكل صراحه لا نستطيع ان نسمح
لمززوجين الجنسيه او العسكريين الترشح الا
وفق ضوابط معينه يجب ان تتم في القاعده
الدستوريه ولكن للاسف هم يريدون ان
متزوجين الجنسيه والعسكريين يترشحوا بدون
اي بدون اي ضوابط اوسس يعني توضع في
القاعده السوريه نحن نتفق مع الدكتور فيما
ذهب اليه الاول بالنسبه لنا الان هي
الانتخابات
وضع قاعده دستوريه تحديد الانتخابات
والذهاب الان الاوان لتوحيد السلطه
التشريعيه في ليبيا يعني نحن رؤيتنا تتم
الصلاه للبرلمانيه اولا ثم بعد ذلك
الرئاسيه وهمم يتولى البرلمان القادم من
النظر في المناصب السياديه
يعني الان يعني مثلا الترحيل ال- ال-
الانتخابات
والبدء في في في في المناسب السيديه
وتغيير الحكومه هي من ليست م- في الترتيب
اولوياتنا يعني الحقيقه يعني في المجلس
وهذا طبعا جل رؤيه اعضاء المجلس في همم
هؤلاء ولكن في النهايه هي مثلا خادعه الى
التصوير داخل المجلس وسيسوه المجلس على
على هذه الخارطه
الخلافات السياسيه فهي تسوى بالحوار كما
تقول سفاره الامريكيه سيفرج الدردور واختم
بعد معك التي دعت همم ضمان اجراء
الانتخابات الذات صدقيه
وشفافه وجامع وتقول ايضا ان التهديد
اللجوء الى بالقوه يزعزع الاستقرار ويقوي
جهود الوحده الوطنيه ولا يمكنه ان يعالج
في شكل دائمه بيونات السياسيه الكل
المتمسك بالانتخابات في ليبيا ولكن
لانتخابات حتى الان وكثيرون لم يستخلصوا
العبر من السياسيين الذين يحكمون حتى الان
همم للاسف يبدو ان ضيفي همم سيد فرج
الدردور لا يستمع اليه لا تستمع اليه سيد
يتفرج
فقدنا الاتصال به على كل نشكره جزيل شكر
يبقى سؤال معلق ربما الى الحلقه
المقبله كل الشكر الجزيل لكما
السيد شعبان ابو سته عضو المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في ليبيا واا سيد فرج الدردور هل
انت معي
فقدنا الاتصال معه يتم تاكيد الامر له على
كل شعبان المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
على سلبيات هذه الدعوه كلها شكرا يا سيد
فرج الدردور الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي كنتم معنا في فقره وجها شكرا